it's a millionaire themed hour right
here on the Dave Ramsey show we're
talking to real millionaires not
mythical ones that people talk about in
the news but people who actually have
done it there by dispensing away with
all the mythology around millionaires so
far I've talked to three by the way and
none of them had wealth because they
inherited it zero I didn't talk to a
single person that's a crook yet I
forgot to ask them all if they were
crooks but none of them sounded like
crooks they didn't sound like people
that had ripped people off I mean they
were project managers and accountants
and people in management stuff like that
I didn't hear anybody that was stealing
from someone I haven't talked to a
single NFL star yet not none of these
people were famous to my knowledge
anyway they didn't mention they were
famous if that was the case and none of
them have had over a 3.5 GPA so the
mythology out there that you can't be a
millionaire is a lie am i helping you
with this
I hope so that's the purpose of the hour
all right Jay is with us Jay's in
Lincoln Nebraska hey Jay how are you
good how are you doing better than I
deserve what's your net worth sir it's
right at 3 million dollars cool and
break that down for me what's it
invested in now a million dollars in
retirement like the Roth and 457 and
then we've got about 1.7 million in real
estate and then we've got about 300
thousand in cash which is mostly unusual
funds just a little bit of cash sitting
there like our emergency fund and stuff
like that cool
very well done how old are you 52 good
job excellent job how much of the three
million dollars did you inherit zero
zero okay
and what has been your average income
through your working lifetime uh the
average would probably be about 75
thousand the the most I've made would be
about ninety eight thousand that's why
I'm at right now never made over a
hundred uh no never cool what do you do
for a living I'm a captain on the fire
department
okay very good excellent you have a
four-year degree yeah I've got a degree
in fire science and emergency management
in EMF and you know my GPA in college
was good but you know the thing of it is
is I was a major screw off in high
school and you know grade school in
elementary and you know so it's you know
it took a while for me to realize when
you get out on your own you got to kick
it up and that's when you know I shot my
GPA up again I get college so what was
your GPA in college it was right at the
four-four oh okay so you had it in you
you just weren't doing it before college
cool very cool I did not know there was
a fire Sciences for your degree I just
learned something that's very neat so
how much of this money is there because
you borrowed money to invest well none
of it is from doing that you know we
took out our mortgage and you know but
none of it is to invest in anything it
was just we build it okay all right and
what part has giving played
theologically or practically in your in
your working lifetime while you were
earning this money
oh we do it all the time it's it's it
comes right off the top of anything we
make and we're somewhere in the 15 to 20
percent and we enjoyed doing it you know
holiday seasons we you know quick little
story we go to Walmart and we we stock
people and see who who might need
something and we'll give them a gift
card we've had a couple of people when
we walked up and give them a gift card
they'll throw it on the floor thinking
something's wrong with it and then we
have to go grab it and take it back to
them and tell them what's going on I
love it that's fun so what's the most
expensive pair of jeans you ever bought
well yeah since I became over 20
probably 10 bucks under 20 probably a
hundred bucks okay I love it before you
were a millionaire how many new cars did
you buy uh I was trying to figure that
out I bought one back and I think it was
1988 otherwise nothing even close to a
new car I prefer just to buy a a good
used ISA vehicle
vehicle gotcha okay and how many
non-fiction books do you read here Oh
as many as I got time to read you know
some of the older ones that I really
like is stuff you talk about the wealthy
barber The Millionaire Next Door that
kind of stuff I just absolutely love you
have your books and then all these new
books you guys are putting out are great
to read and we buy your books and hand
them out to people when I when I hand
out a book to somebody I can tell you if
they're going to succeed or not because
the ones that succeed usually read your
book in about three days they're done
welcome ones that you know the ones that
go yeah I read a chapter and set it down
well they never they never pick it back
up then again it's the ones I can't put
it down that are the ones that succeed
exactly that's interesting that's very
interesting so the 25 year old version
of you is out there walking around Jay
what would you tell him if he wanted to
be a millionaire he's listening to a
millionaire's worth was no guy worth
three million dollars right now what
would you tell him well the hardest
thing is it's it's hard and you just
can't give up I'm a Dave I owe you an
apology because there's many times I was
cussing at you because I wanted
something and I wanted something now and
your name always came up because of it
you know what I what I tell the new
paramedics that I have on the crew I
tell them you control the situation
don't let the situation control you it's
like driving a car you can steer it
where you want it to go or you can let
go of the steering wheel you're going to
crash and it's the same way with your
finances so do you think it's possible
for someone 25 today to end up where you
are when they're 52 oh they should be
there faster than me because you know I
really didn't kick it in until I
stumbled upon you on the radio probably
I'm guessing 20 years ago somewhere in
that range and you know at first I
thought okay I can do half what you're
saying I'll be okay well you're going to
get half or less of the results if you
don't follow it exactly so you know it
took me a little while to figure it out
but once I did yeah so anybody anybody
can do it it's hard
but you just got to keep after it and
realize there's going to be downtime so
that's where you need a support system
do you think you screwed up your life by
saying no to yourself so that now you
have this position no no not at all and
then there's times on the outside
jumping around and flopping around like
a fish out of water because I wanted
something and couldn't get it but you
know the other thing too is you've got
that your ELP network and you need to
find a really good ELP and we've got a
really good one Erin out of Lawrence
Kansas that dick he works with us and
we'll more of a friend than we are
anything else and that person is defying
somebody they can trust if you just
don't have that bond it look elsewhere
you know until you get that bond where
they treat you like they're family
mother Helen you're three million
dollars they're our family yeah yeah
yeah yeah I love it
dude you're a great American hero it's
an honor to talk to you thank you for
sharing your story thank you very cool
stuff J is a fireman in Lincoln Nebraska
captain I think he said um maybe the
fire chief I don't know maybe I
misunderstood but he's the chief ok
Kelly's saying he's the chief so but
he's obviously doing done very well
never made over a hundred three million
dollar net worth see it you guys that
are Millennials you're getting fed a
book of lies and some of you are writing
blogs that make you look stupid because
you're saying it can't be done
I got sitting there he said he could he
said you could do it faster than he did
it in today's world with today's dollars
with today's problems yeah don't let
people tell you you can't win on America
today it's not Pollyanna it's not the
power of positive thinking
it's just try not being stupid and
defeatist those are things will kill you
they really will more millionaires on
the Dave Ramsey show coming up hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind